If it doesn't disturb you,...
...can I ask you about aging in Korea?
I heard the number of aging people is increasing in Korea.
That's right.
Korea became an aging society since 2007.
According to statistics,...
...even though Korea is now only in the preliminary stage,...
...it will soon become a super - aged society with 14 percent of the population being elderly...
...by 2018, and 20 percent by 2026.
I also heard that...
...this is a direct result of dramatically decreased birth rates...
...and longer life expectancies.
I even heard something like the average life span of Koreans will be extended...
...from 75.9 years old in 2001 to 81.5 years old in 2030,...
...which is the same level of developed countries.
Wow, what a surprise!
I didn't know how fast this was happening.
Well, then Koreans should start preparing well for an aging society, right?
You're right. I agree with you.
Everybody will get old soon.
We are not an exception.
If we do not prepare for the aging society,...
...Korea will experience some painful days ahead.
Time will go fast...
...and I want everybody to be happy in the future.
I fully agree with what you said.
To be more specific,...
...the Korean government and the private sector...
...should closely work together on this problem...
...so there should be more jobs especially for old people in the future.
I can see most of the elderly in Korea are not working...
...because there is no company which hires them.
I believe the implementation of support...
...policies for the elderly is also important.